شكرا للزميل نايف نستكمل هذه التغطيه
للاحتجاجات العارمه التي تشهدها فرنسا حيث
تشهد فرنسا يوما عاشرا من الاحتجاجات
العارمه ضد قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي
دفعت به الحكومه وسط معارضه شعبيه كبيره
كما نشاهد في الصور وقد اعلن وزير
الداخليه جرار دارمان نشره ثلاثه عشر الف
شرطي بينهم خمسه الاف
وخمسمائه في باريس وحدها في تعزيزات غير
مسبوقه
وفيما اعلنت نقابه عمال النظافه في فرنسا
تعليق اضرابها اعتبارا من الغرب عرض نواب
من يمين الوسط الوساطه بين الحكومه
الفرنسيه والنقابات فيما يستمر قطع
الطرقات منذ عده ايام ما تسبب باضطرابات
في امدادات الوقود في بعض المناطق
الفرنسيه
وقد قطعت طرقات صباح اليوم حول
البلاد فيما شهدت حركه القطارات اضطرابات
كبيره
هذا وتفاقمت الاحتجاجات اعزائي المشاهدين
ضد التعديل الذي طرحه الرئيس الفرنسي
ورفع من خلاله سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى
64 عاما منذ تبنت الحكومه النص دون تصويت
في الجمعيه العامه فيما لم تؤدي اقتراحات
بحجب الثقه الى الاطاحه بالحكومه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا ما زلنا واياكم مع هذه الصور العارمه
للتظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي تشهدها فرنسا
لليوم العاشر على التوالي وهي تزداد يوما
بعد يوم من دون وجود اي بوادر حتى الساعه
لحلول وسط مع نشر
الحكومه الفرنسيه لاكثر من ثلاثه عشر الف
شرطي في سابقه في باريس وحدها للتصدي لاي
اعمال العنف وكان لافتا اليوم كلام وزير
الداخليه جرار الذي تحدث عن وجود الف
متطرف استخدام مصطلح الف متطرف داخل
الحشود المحتجه والذين يريدون ان يمارسوا
اعمال عنف او القيام باعمال عنف
وانهم اتوا من خارج البلاد لم يحدد من اين
تحديدا هذا كلام لوزير الداخلي الفرنسي
هذا اليوم هنالك حديث ايضا عن تقوم بها او
يقوم بها نواب من يمين الوسط بين الطرفين
بين النقابات والحكومه الفرنسيه ولكن حتى
الساعه
لا وجود لاي معطيات تشير الى ان هذه
الوساطه قد افلحت لان كلا الطرفين متمدرس
حول موقفه مع العلم ان الرئيس مكروه قال
اليوم انه مستعد لبحث هذا القانون مع
النقابات فقط استخدام مصطلح بحث وليس
تجميد العمل بهذا القانون او تعديل هذا
القانون
كما ذكرنا
ماكرون يقول مستعد لبحث قانون التقاعد مع
النقابات بعد حسمه في المجلس الدستوري
الىوك الذي يتابع كل هذه التظاهرات فادي
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد من عندك
في هذه المشاهد تنبي بليله اكثر سخونه من
سابقاتها
[موسيقى]
اهلا طالب هذه هي توقعات كل الاطراف هنا
في فرنسا خصوصا الجانب الامني من خلال
قوات الشرطه وايضا وزير الداخليه وزير
الداخليه جلال درمنا حذر من وجود عناصر من
شباب اليسار المتطرف وايضا من عدد كبير من
هؤلاء قديمه من خارج فرنسا للمشاركه في
هذه التظاهرات وافتعال بعض الحوادث
والاشتباكات مع قوه الشرطه حتى الان
الموكب الفارسي يسير بهدوء لا يوجد
اشتباكات او مناوشات بين المتظاهرين
والشرطه هناك عدد من المصارف التي قامت
بحمايه واجهتها الزجاجيه وهي اكثر الاماكن
المستهدفه في هذه التظاهرات قامت بحمايه
هذه الواجهات من خلال تركيب واجهات خشبيه
او معدنيه لكن هنا على يسار الشاشه هناك
احد المصارف الذي ربما لم يصعفه الوقت
لحمايه واجهاته والموكب الان يقترب منه
ربما ستكون هذه نقطه البدايه للمواجهات
هناك عبارات مكتوبه على واجهات هذه المصرف
عبارات معاديه او ضد الرئيس الفرنسي وايضا
ضد وزير الداخليه هناك عباره مكتوبه اساسا
اي وزير الداخليه قاتل طبعا هذه التظاهرات
ما تزال مستمره في كل الشوارع او في كل
المدن الفرنسيه هناك مواجهات حدثت في
مدينه ليون وسط وجنوب فرنسا هناك ايضا
مواجهات في مدينه وفي مدينه رين لكن الان
الموكب الباريسي ما زال يحافظ على هدوءه
لكن هناك بالطبع خشيه من حدوث بعض
المواجهات وعمليات التخريب خصوصا في ساعات
المساء لان في هذا التوقيت هناك عدد كبير
من المتظاهرين الذين هم من شريحه الطلاب
والشبان الذين يبداون تظاهراتهم الخاصهم
بعضهم يتواجد في هذه المواكب التي تنظمها
النقابات لكن ايضا هم بدل لديهم توقيتهم
الخاص للتظاهر وهم الذين يقومون بهذه
الافعال في شوارع العاصمه خصوصا
مشاهد حرق القمامه المتكدسه في شوارع
العاصمه باريس اعتقد ان الان سيقومون
بمهاجمه المصرف هناك حركه حول هذا المصرف
يعني في بعض المشاهد تردنا الان من ليل من
مدينه ليل من مدينه ليل
للاحتجاجات
فادي فادي انت وفق متابعتك انت تتابع هذه
الاوضاع وهذه التظاهرات منذ ان بدات عدد
المتظاهرين يزداد يوما بعد يوم ام لا يعني
مع ان الحكومه الفرنسيه تراهن على الوقت
كي تبرد همه المحتجين وهذا ما لم يتم حتى
الساعه يعني على الاقل الاعداد عم تزداد
ام لا عم بتلاحظ انه عم بتقل ام ماذا
الاعداد او الزخم بشكل عام هو مستمر منذ
اسابيع هو لا ينقص بل يكون كل يوم اكثر من
الذي قبل خصوصا الاسبوع الماضي هناك ثلاثه
ملايين ونصف المليون شخص شاركوا في
التظاهرات في العاصمه وحدها جمعت التظاهر
الفارسيه نحو 800 الف متظاهر طبعا هذه
الارقام كلها وفقا للنقبات وزاره الداخليه
تتحدث عن ارقام اقل بكثير وهناك دائما هذه
هذا النوع من المعركه في الارقام بين
وزاره الداخليه والنقابات طبعا التظاهرات
اليوم لم يخرج اي احصائيه حتى الان لاعداد
المتظاهرين لكن هذه الاحصائيات عاده ما
تخرج بعد انتهاء التظاهرات او عندما تقترب
من نهايتها الشرطه تصدر من جهتها
الاحصائيات والنقابات ايضا خلال هذه
التظاهرات او قبل انطلاق الموكب الفارسي
اعلنت الشرطه عن اعتقال 11 شخصا كان
بحوزتهم عدد من الادوات الحاده كما انها
قالت انها اجرت عمليات تفتيش لاكثر من
5500 شخص في عموم انحاء البلاد في
التظاهرات التي تنظم في كل المدن الفرنسيه
هؤلاء كان بحوزتهم بعض الادوات الحاده
وهناك هذه العمليات عمليات التفتيش
والاعتقالات اجريت لمنع حدوث نوع من
الاشتباكات او الصدامات بين الشرطه
والمتظاهرين لكن حتى الان الموكب الباريسي
كما ذكرت هو يسير بهدوء حذر مع احتمال
حدوث المواجهات في الساعات المقبله هل
يمكن يعني التنبؤ كيف يمكن ان تتطور
الامور في الساعات المقبله والى اي مدى
ستبقى التظاهرات سلميه اذا ما اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار تصريحات وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه
جرار
منذ هذا اليوم والذي تحدث عن وجود الف
متطرف استخدم مصطلح متطرف قدموا من الخارج
لم يحدد من اين تحديدا وقال من الخارج
للمشاركه في هذه التظاهرات
نعم طالب نحن عندما نرى هؤلاء الاشخاص
الذين ترونهم على الشاشه يرتدون لباسا
اسود وهم مقنعين هؤلاء هم الذين يقصدهم
وزير الداخليه ويصفهم بالعناصر المتطرفه
هؤلاء عموما هم من شريحه الشباب هم من
شباب احزاب اليسار او من الذين ينتمون
بعضهم الى احزاب اليسار
ومساله التطرف هذه هناك اعتراض كبير عليها
وانتقادات من قبل الاحزاب اليساريه على
سبيل المثال زعيم حزب فرنسا غير الخاضعه
اليساريرا ديكالي قبل يومين انما يقوم به
المتظاهرون من عمليات حرق
للقمامه في الشوارع هذه المسائل هي عاديه
جدا ولا تؤذي لان لو كنا نريد التحدث عن
عناصر متطرفه فعلينا الذهاب او علينا
العوده الى سنوات طويله للوراء من تاريخ
الاحتجاجات الفرنسيه عندما كانت تلقى يلقى
الاثاث من النوافذ على عناصر الشرطه في
فترات من تاريخ فرنسا هو يقول ان هؤلاء لا
يفتعلون شغبا وهذا ايضا تقريبا ما يقوله
المتظاهرون انفسهم لانهم في الواقع لا
يهاجمون مرافق عامه بشكل كبير واتحدث بشكل
خاص عن تظاهرات الطلاب التي يتم اشعال
الحرائق فيها هؤلاء يقومون باشعال الحرائق
بحسب ما تمكنا من رصده خلال الايام
الماضيه عندما كنا نرافقهم يقومون باشعال
هذه الحرائق فقط من اجل تاخير قوات الشرطه
التي تلاحقهم وهناك كتيبه من عناصر الشرطه
تقود هي تكون على دراجات ناريه هذه
الكتيبه معروفه بتدخلها العنيف جدا في مثل
هذا النوع من التظاهرات هذه الحرائق كانت
بهدف تاخير تقدمهم وملاحقتها للمتظاهرين
وبالمناسبه هناك سته عشره تحقيقا فتح بحق
عناصر من هؤلاء الشرطه بحسب ما اعلن قائد
شرطه باريس لانهم قاموا بتجاوز بعض عمليات
الاعتقال قوموا بتنفيذ العمليات اعتقال
عنيفه قاموا بالاعتداء على متظاهرين وكذلك
ايضا
عدد من الصحفيين في اخر تظاهره الاسبوع
الماضي هناك ايضا عريضه شعبيه توقع الان
وجمعت اكثر من 100 الف توقيع لحل هذه
الكتيبه وهي تسمى
اي قوات التدخل السريع في حالات العنف
هؤلاء
العناصر الشرطه يكونون على دراجات ناريه
ويقومون بضرب المتظاهرين وهم على دراجاتهم
يقومون بتدخل عنيف جدا وهناك انتقادات
كبيره جدا حتى ان
قام بالدعوه الى حل هذه الكتيبه من قوات
الشرطه طالب
فادي هنالك وساطه او سمها مبادره يقوم بها
نواب يمين الوسط بين الطرفين
حتى الساعه هل تملك هذه المبادره اي فرصه
ام ان ما قد تم تم يعني والان الى الشارع
در
حتى الان هذه الوساطه الحكومه رفضتها قالت
او المتحدث باسم الحكومه الفرنسيه قال
صباح اليوم في تعليقه على هذه المبادره ان
المساله لا تحتاج الى وساطه للحديث بين
الرئيس الفرنسي والنقابات لانه بالاساس
دعا الى هذا الحوار وقال ان يده ممدوده
لهؤلاء النقابيين الذين يخوضون هذه
المعركه في الشارع لكن ايضا هناك مبادره
اخرى يقوم تقوم بها احدى النقابات
الثمانيه التي تدعو الى هذه التظاهرات
وحركه الاضراب وتتعلق بان يقوم الرئيس
بسحب الماده السابعه من قانون التقاعد
المثير للجدل
الاستغناء عن الماده التي ترفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما حتى الان لا يوجد رد من
الحكومه على هذا المقترح كما انه لا ليس
مقترحا من كل النقابات حتى الان المقترح
الوحيد من النقابات الثمانيه متحده هو
القيام
بمبادره لوجود او للبحث عن وسطه
حوار بين قصر الاليزيه والنقابات خصوصا
وان الرئيس في الفتره الماضيه رفض اللقاء
مع النقابات لكن اليوم ربما الوضع اختلف
قليلا ربما بدا الرئيس يخضع لضغط الشارع
ولخطوره ما قد تؤول اليه الامور لذلك هو
اعلن هذه المبادره عن انفتاحه للحديث مع
النقابات لكن رئيس الحكومه الفرنسيه تقول
لن نؤجل تطبيق اصلاح نظام التقاعد ابدا
شكرا لك فادي داهوك مراسل العربيه كنت معي
من باريس تتابع هذه التظاهرات العارمه
والعارمه جدا كما
نشاهد سنكون معك في سياق هذه التغطيه
مجددا في الساعات المقبله انتقل الان الى
هذه الصور التي وردتنا من ليل من مدينه
ليل وهذه المواجهات بين قوات الشرطه
والمحتجين والمتظاهرين مشاهد القاء زجاجات
على
افراد الشرطه
هذه وحده مكافحه الشغب كما كما نشاهد
ومواجهات
ومشاكسات بين
المحتجين وقوات الشرطان وشاهد ايضا قنابل
بعض قنابل الغاز التي تطلق في هذه المشاهد
المحتجون يرمون قوات الشرطه ومكافحه الشغب
ببعض الادوات وبعض الزجاجات هذه اذا في
احد الشوارع الرئيسيه في مدينه ليل
الفرنسيه كنا ذكرنا منذ قليل ان رئيس
الحكومه الفرنسيه
اكدت ان الحكومه الفرنسيه لن تؤجل تطبيق
اصلاح نظام التقاعد بمعنى ان القانون بات
ساريه المفعول وستطبقه الحكومه ايا تكن
هذه الاحتجاجات على الاقل هذا ما تقوله
رئيسه الحكومه الفرنسيه الى باريس ولمزيد
من
التحليل ينضم الي المحلل السياسي طارق
اهلا وسهلا بك كيف يمكن ان تتطور الامور
برايك الى عماده ستبقى هذه التظاهرات
سلميه ام لا يعني وراء الاكمه ما وراءها
والامور والامور لا تمضي بخير صح التعبير
في الساعات المقبله
تحياتي يا سيدي شكرا للاستضافه يعني انا
اريد ان ابدا حديثي بما سمعته قبل ان ناتي
الى استوديو بالتحديد من
السيد الذي هو رئيس فرنسا الابيه بالقول
ان علينا التهدئه هو يدعو الى التهدئه هو
راى ما حصل بما نسميه في الاسبوع الماضي
عندما كان هناك تظاهره لها علاقه
بالبحيرات المائيه الصناعيه الذي الحكومه
سمحت
لتصريفها او للعمل بها وكان هناك يعني عنف
غير طبيعي لذلك انا برايي السيد ميلونشون
هو يبحث عن التهدئه ولكن بنفس الوقت هو
كالعاده يرسل رسائل سياسيه وبالتحديد الى
رئيسه الحكومه والى رئيس الجمهوريه بالقول
انكم لا يجب ان تناموا على على سريركم لان
هذا الموضوع غير غير ممكن
لان هذا القانون هو قانون الضر في في
الحياه
الاولنا الاجتماعيه في فرنسا وفي مفهومه
ايضا هو لما سيكون لاحقا اما
عمليه فقط فقط هذه الجزئيه طيب اذا صح ما
قلته بان السيد جلوك دعا الى التهدئه ولكن
هل يملك السيد ميلونشون ناصيه القرار
للضغط على الجميع على جميع المحتجين
المتظاهرين النقابات وكلمته مسموعه ام لا
هو يمثل ربما يعني فريقا ليس وازنا في هذه
التظاهرات
هو محرك اساسي يا سيدي يجب ان نفهم جيدا
ان الشارع مرتبط
بالنقبات من ناحيه والحركه اليسريه التي
رصها هو يعني المعارضه اليساريه التي هو
يراسها بالتحديد فرنسا الابيه والنيوبيس
يعني تجمع اليسار لحزب الاشتراكي الحزب
الشيوعي والخضر كل هؤلاء هو الوجه الرئيسي
لكل هؤلاء وهو يلعب دائما على ما نسميه
ايضا الوجوه جديده يعني الوجوه الجديده
التي هي وجود الشباب بالتحديد الجامعيين
وطلبه السنويات هو الذي حركهم هو الذي قال
ابنهم ان هذا مستقبلكم وعليكم ان تكونوا
موجودين في الشارع لذلك انا برايي الان هو
مسؤول وهو يتحمل مسؤوليه بمفهوم السياسي
يا سيدي ولكن بنفس الوقت ليس هو المسؤول
ان تدخل ان دخل داخل هؤلاء المتظاهرين نوع
من ما نسميه الفرق التي تريد التخريب فقط
للتخريب ولكن بنفس الوقت هو يستطيع ان
يقول اننا ممكن قد نسير بما نسميه على
الضغط قوي على الحكومه للوصول الى شيء ما
وانا برايي موضوع التي نتكلم عنه الان وهو
الوساطه يعني هذا فعلا هذا يضر بالحكومه
وليس يفيدها بمعنى هذا يقول ان الحكومه لا
تستجيب الا بما نسميه شخصا جديد يدخل على
الساحه لكي يطري او لكي يعني يفتح قنوات
جديده ما بينهم وما بين الحكومه وبين
المتظاهرين او بالتحديد النقابات وانا
برايي للاسف الشديد يعني بما انه هذا
الحزب الوسط اللي هو الحركه الديمقراطيه
والتي هي شريك بالحكم لان لديها وزيرين في
الحكومه التي هي تطرح هذا الموضوع وهذا
باعتقادي قد يكون عائقا ايضا لما نسميه
وضع هذه يعني هذه المبادره حيز العمل فورا
لانه الموضوع بالنسبه للرئيس الجمهوريه هو
ينتظر جواب من المحكمه الدستوريه ورئيسه
الحكومه تقول وبكل صراحه انا انتظر كل ذلك
لابدا
بتسيير هذا القانون ولكن كما علمنا ان هذا
القانون لن يكون فاعلا الا عندما يقوم
رئيس الجمهوريه بالمصادقه عليه وسيبدا ذلك
ابتداء من الاول من سبتمبر للعام يعني
العام 2023 لذلك انا باعتقادي الان الشارع
يملك ما نسميه القوه
السياسيه ليقول للجميع ان حتى اللحظه لا
توجد اذان صاغيه للاسف الشديد نحن في امام
حوار طرشان ما بين الحكومه وبين النقابات
اكثر من ذلك عندما نسمع ان بعض النقابات
تريد تفريغ القانون وخصوصا مسح الماده
السابعه اذن ما معنى كل هذا القانون اذا
لم توجد الماده السابعه التي اعتمد عليها
اعتمدت عليها الحكومه ورئيس الجمهوريه
بالقول ان اذا نفذ يعني رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64
يعني سنكسب قليلا من الديون التي نضعها
الان في هذه الصناديق التقاعديه التي لم
تعد قادره ان تدفع كل الرواتب التقاعد
لافت اليوم في كلام وزير الداخليه يعني
كلام اقل ما يمكن ان يقال عنه انه خطير هو
قال ان الف متطرف استخدم مصطلح متطرف
قدموا من خارج فرنسا طب ما هذا كمان يعني
يستدعي التساؤل من وين من الخارج
لم يحدد من اي للمشاركه في هذه التظاهرات
والقيام باعمال العنف هل هذا الكلام حقيقي
ودقيق ام لا في اطار اعطاء مشروعيه لاي
عنف قد تستخدمه الشرطه الفرنسيه لتفخيط
التظاهرات في الايام المقبله
مصادر وزاره الداخليه تعتمد على الحادث
الذي حصل كما قلت لك الاسبوع الماضي
بمنطقه قريبه من ضواحي باريس الكبرى والتي
كانت لها علاقه مظاهره ضد انشاء ما نسميه
بحيرات
اصطناعيه لموضوع الري
للاراضي الشاسعه والكبيره بهذه المنطقه
وهنا
يعني استخبارات وزاره الداخليه قالت ان
هناك اشخاصا قدموا حتى متخصصين بمعنى لانه
عندما تحرق مثلا اربعه سيارات
لدرك الفرنسي ويوجد هناك درون درون ليس
للشرطه ولكن للمتظاهرين يرسل معلومات لكل
المتظاهرين للكر والفر وللقدوم من ناحيه
مختلفه وكان يعني هناك فعلا ساحه معركه في
هذه المنطقه بالتحديد لذلك انا برايي وزير
الداخليه يحاول ان يعبر ان هناك بعض
الاشخاص الذين قدموا اما من بلجيكا واما
من فرنسا من المانيا عفوا باتجاه فرنسا
لمعاونه بعض الاطراف النقابيين هذا جد مهم
وهذا رايناه بما نسميه يعني التواصل ما
بين النقابات وبالتحديد نقابات مثلا
العمال التي لها علاقه بالنقل البري او
حتى
النقابات اللي سلاح علاقه بالقطارات وهذا
التواصل ما بين هذه النقابات وهذا ليست
اتهام هذا موجود باوروبا عامه يعني هناك
انفتاح لكل النقابات على بعضها البعض وهي
تساند بعضها وتساند بعضها ايضا ماديا يعني
يجب ان نفتح ما نسميه موضوع الموضوع
المادي لانه اليوم المتظاهرين المضربين
ليس لا لا يقبضوا اجورهم ولذلك فتحت منصات
على
لكي يتبرع الناس والبارحه كنت انظر الى
احد المنصات التي وصلت الى تقريبا ثلاثه
مليون يورو
جد مهم يعطي قوه بالمفهوم المعنوي والماده
لهؤلاء للاستمرار بالاضراب وايضا لحاجه
اخرين لمساندتهم في هذا الاضراب هلا
المسؤوليه التي يتحملها وزير الداخليه
بالقول ان هناك اشخاص غرباء دخلوا هذه
مسؤوليه انا باعتقادي يجب ان يوزعها ايضا
على الاتحاد الاوروبي بمعنى انه هل توجد
بمفهوم اوروبول التي هي الشرطه الاوروبيه
تناسق او يعني تواصل بمعلومات لكي نصل الى
ما نسميه وقف هؤلاء بمنطقه معينه او العمل
على ايقاف هؤلاء ان كان قديمه بالقطار او
قدموا بالباصات او حتى قدموا بسيارات لكي
يكون هناك معلومات واضحه ولكن انا
باعتقادي وزاره الداخليه قد ترفع بهذا
الرقم لكي تقول انها بحاجه ايضا
لقوات اخرى لمساندتها لان الموضوع لم يعد
نحن عم نحكي يعني مثل استطراضا
يعني لو قلنا خمسه اشخاص 10 اشخاص 50 شخص
نتكلم عن الف يعني اليس في الامر مبالغه
كبيره
ها لانه حقيقه انت معك حق مئه بالمئه
القول بالف الف شخصيه وكانه كوماندوس قادم
الى باريس في هذه المظاهره طيب المحلل
السياسي الاستاذ طارق وهبي شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه كنت مع من باريس ايضا
لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم الي من باريس الان
المحلل السياسي حسان القطبي اعزائي
المشاهدين ما زلنا واياكم بهذه الصور
المباشره لهذه التظاهرات العارمه في باريس
في هذا اليوم العاشر من التظاهرات
والاحتجاجات على قانون التقاعد استاذ حسان
اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه اولا اريد
قراءتك اهلا وسهلا اريد قراءتك لمجريات
الامور وهل الجميع يعني بات مقتنعا يعني
انه لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت الشارع
والجميع الى الشارع دور ام لا ثمت وسطات
قد تنجح في لملمه الامور قبل ان تنفلت من
عقالها ان صح التعبير
تحيه سيدي الكريم يبدو ان لا صوت يعلو في
صوت الشارع الشارع يتحول الى اله ياكل
الاخضر واليابس الخوف كل الخوف هو ان
تتحول هذه المظاهرات التي تشرف عليها
النقابات وتتحمل مسؤوليتها النقابات الى
مواجهات بين المتظاهرين والامن هذا هو
التخوف الكبير لان ما رايناه الخميس
المنصرم كان بوادر انتفاضه شعبيه ثم جاء
يوم وجاءت هذه الحركه يعني حركه
في منطقه سانسونيت وكان اشعال نار في في
سيارات الشرطه تخوف الكبير اليوم في فرنسا
ان تتحول المظاهرات والمطالب التي تطالب
بسحب هذا القانون الى مواجهات في الشارع
هذا كل الخوف بان تعرف ان تصاعدي الخميس
الفارط هناك يعني شد وجذب بين نقابات
وقوات الشرطه كذلك في مسجد الارقام
النقبات تقول 3.5 مليون
يعني محافظه الشرطه تقول مليون وبعض ونيف
يعني هناك هناك تواصل للحركه الاحتجاجيه
الجديد في هذا الاسبوع هو ان النقبات
الطلابيه نزلت الى الشراء اليوم بالامس
كنت امام يعني صدفه كنت امام جامعه
قريدوفيل الاجتماع اجتماع النقابات
الطلابيه كان في الشارع اغلقت الجامعه
وضعوا لافته يعني اما سحب القانون او سوف
ندخل في البلوكاش
وكان الاستماع اجتماع العلاقات الطلابيه
من كل الجامعات فرنسا تقريبا امام الجامعه
في الطريق العام
اعتقد ان كذلك خروج الطلاب هو معطى جديد
ومهم ويجمع السقوطات الفرنسيه ان تاخذه في
بعين الاعتبار طيب سؤال الاستطراضي اذا
استاذ حسان هل ستبقى سلميه ام ثمه من يريد
ان يدفع بها الى العنف وسقوط ضحايا
نعم حقيقه سؤال مهم جدا ونتمنى قبل كل شيء
ان تبقى في اطار في اطار سلمى لان لان رفع
العنف من كلا الجانبين حتى يوم الخميس حتى
يوم السبت كان هناك سقوط لجرحى من الطرفين
سواء من المتظاهرين او من الشرطه وبعض
الحالات كانت حالتهم حرجه الانزلاق الى
العنف هنا خطير شخصيا في بحوث على
اكاديميه اشتغل على الدوافع عدم الاستقرار
السياسي ومن مظاهر عدم استغلال السياسي هو
العمق من اجل دوافع سياسيه يعني عندما
تكون هناك دوافع سياسيه ويتحول تحول هذه
الدوافع الى عمق تبدا من الاحتجاجات او من
المواجهات بين الشرطه تصل ربما في بعض
الحالات ممكن حتى ليس هنا الحال في فرنسا
بصفه عامه الى حتى الدوافع الاختيارات
السياسيه لطباعه الاختيار السياسيه ليس
هذا الاطار في فرنسا ولا نتحدث عن مواجهات
عنيفه السبت راينا في في مثل منفصله عن
قانون التقاعد مثل
هي مجموعات
هذه المجموعات العنيفه التي ترتدي اللون
الاسود التي تخرج في المظاهرات
ودائما هنا هنا مرد التساؤل يا استاذ حسان
لانه وزير الداخليه وعلى لسانه تحدث عن
وجود ما يقارب من الف وصفهم يعني استخدم
توصيف المتطرف من الف متطرف قدموا من خارج
فرنسا للمشاركه في هذه التظاهرات لا ادري
اذا كان في الكلام مبالغه من قبله ولكن
هذا يؤشر الى ان الحكومه الفرنسيه تتحسب
لسيناريوهات لن تكون سلميه في هذه
التظاهرات اذا ما صح الحديث عن الف متطرف
قدمه من خارج فرنسا فرنسا حسب ما يقول
وزير الداخليه
بربنه يعني كلامها دائما يجب ان تاخذه
بكامل الصيغه الاجماليه ولكن ما نعرفه
معهدناه ونحن نتابع المشهد الفرنسي منذ
سنوات ان هناك مجموعه اقول جيدا فرنسيه لا
اعرف ان كانت لديها معلومات اخرى هذا امكن
شان اخر ولكن نعرف ان هناك مجموعات هي
مجموعه فرنسيه ترتدي اللون الاسود في كل
مظاهرات كلما ينزل الليل وهي تبدا في
العمل التقريبيه تهشيم السيارات تحسين
المحلات التجاريه في بعض الاحيان تحولت
حتى الى عمليات ذهب وسرق للمغازات رايناها
في الحمله الصفراء ولكن يعني الف شخص من
خارج فرنسا هذا على عقده وزاره الداخليه
ممكن سوف سوف فيما بعد اكيد ان كذلك يجب
ان نقول ان هناك استمرار امني كبير وكل
الاجهزه الفرنسيه تقريبا تعمل حتى تمتلك
الامور وتذهب الى منحى لا يحمد عقبه هذا
اكيد هذا شعور السلطات والاجهزه الفرنسيه
ولكن اشخاص ياتون من خارج فرنسا هذه سابقه
طيب رئيسه الحكومه الفرنسيه اكدت او جددت
تاكيد ان الحكومه لن تؤجل تطبيق اصلاح
نظام التقاعد طب في سؤال يعني يطرح نفسه
استاذ حسان لماذا لا تستطيع الحكومه يا
اخي مش التراجع لنقل تجميد القانون الى
اجل غير مسمى افساحا في المجال لوساطه او
الامتصاص غضبت الشارع لماذا لا تستطيع
تجميد القانون مثلا لفتره معينه
يعني هو ماكرون لديه سبقه وتراجع سابقا في
سلطات في حمله الشطرات الصفراء ولكن هناك
فرق بين بين ما يعرف السترات الصفراء 2018
والان في ال 2018 مكرون كان لديه تحدي
انتخابي جديد وكان لدي انتخابات جديده
يعول على النجاح فيها ولكن الان مكروه كما
يقول يعني بالفرنسيه يعني هو رئيس مغادر
لن تكون لديه عهده ثابته في القانون
الفرنسي بالنسبه اليه ليس لديه ما يخساره
اولا ثانيا بالنسبه اليه ان هذا قانون
اصلاح التقاعد هو كان في برنامجه
الانتخابي منذ العهده الاولى اجله للعهد
الثانيه لان يعرف حجم وثيقه لهذا الملف
كما قلت رئيس مغادر ليس لديه ما يخسر يريد
تمريره بالقوه ولكن يجب ان ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار قوه الشارع الفرنسي كذلك
هل سيخرج من هذه المعمعه جريحا وبقوه رئيس
مكروه ام كما تقول الامر سيان بالنسبه
اليه
هو بالنسبه
للماكولوسين يعني ذاهب فيه قال ان القانون
سوف يمر ولن يتراجع ولكن ولكن امام قوه
الشرع كل شيء ممكن او اخذ الشارع منحه
تصاعدي وهذا هو التخوف الحقيقي هنا في
فرنسا واصبحت الاحتجاجات يعني تخرج من
اطار الاحتجاجات السلميه وناس سوف يكون
هناك كلام اخر كلام اخر لان التاريخ العين
بالامس نتنياهو
تراجع بالامس
انه تراجع
جمد يعني على الاقل جمد السير في القانون
يعني هون السؤال انه لماذا الحكومه
الفرنسيه لا تستطيع تجميد لفتره معينه
لامتصاص هضبه الشارع
الحكومه الفرنسيه بين المطرقه والسنجان
سيدي الكريم بين مطرقه اخش الفرنسي وسندان
الضوابط والتوازنات الماليه والاقتصاديه
حتى الاتحاد الاوروبي كان يعني شدد على
فرنسا ان ان عليها ان تقوم ببعض الخطوات
الماليه فرنسا لديها 3000 مليار اورو
كذلك الفرنسيين يعرفون جيدا ان هناك
فاتوره مؤجله سوف يدفعها الفرنسيين اليوم
او غدا هي فاتوره الكوفيد سيدي الكريم لان
ماكرون قبل الانتخابات قدم اموال يعني
كثيره وكثيره للشعب الفرنسي في اطار معونه
اجتماعيه في فتره الحجر الصحي 678 مليار
هو القرض قرض الكوفيد بالنسبه لكل الكتله
الاوروبيه في الوقت الذي كانت المانيا
وهولندا تعارضان هذا على القرض الذي يضمنه
الاتحاد الاوروبي كانت الدول مثل اسبانيا
فرنسا ايطاليا حتى البرتغال تدفع لهذا
القرض هناك
يمكن ان يتراجع لان لديه اليوم
تحديات اقتصاديه كبيره سواء امام
المواجهات الماليه او حتى امام الاقتصاد
الفرنسي قل حتى يعني يعرف الجميع الوضع
العالمي فاتوره الطاقه المرتفعه مع فرنسا
تدفع تقريبا 14% من الناتج الاجمالي
للصناديق الاجتماعي وحتى رقم رقم
المحاليلين على التقاعد سوف يتضاعف
السنوات القادمه نتحدث عن عشرين مليون
متقاعد في سنوات القادمه السنه دي تقريبا
عاجزه تماما
عن دفع هذه يعني من حق التقاعديه لذلك
الحكومه الفرنسيه ويرى مكروه ان في سن
التقاعد من 62 64 قد يكون هو الحل ولكن
كذلك من يعرف الفرنسيين من يعرف
يعني البعد والوزن الاجتماعي في التقاليد
الفرنسيه خاصه منذ حقبه دعني اقول
حققوا مكاسب اجتماعيه كبيره وكبيره جدا
يبدو انهم غير مستعدين للتخلي عليها في
الوقت الحالي انا دائما كنت اتساءل
العديد من الاصدقاء والمتامين بشان
السياسي الفرنسي يعني بالشيكولوجيه
سيكولوجيه هذا المواطن الفرنسي المواطن
الفرنسي صعب
وانت تتحدث يعني الكونفدراليه الفرنسيه
للعمل تؤكد منذ قليل ان الحكومه الفرنسيه
لا تريد التحدث معها يعني الكونفدراليه
الفرنسيه للعمل تقول ان الحكومه الفرنسيه
لا تريد التحدث معنا فقط يعني هذا الكلام
جاء بعد حديث عن وساطه يقوم بها
نواب يمين الوسط بين الطرفين ولكن
الفرنسيه تؤكد منذ قليل
ان الحكومه لا تريد
التحدث
معهم اي اضافه قبل ان انتقل الى المحلل
الاقتصادي الدكتور حسن عبيد هو ينتظرنا
استاذ حسان تفضل يعني نقطه فقط اريد ان
اضيفها بخصوص المعلومه التي
يعني اثقت سيدي الكريم ان اليوم لا مخرج
من هذه الازمه الا بالحوار باعتقادي
الشخصي ان على النقابات مجتمعه مع الحكومه
ان يجلسوا سويا على طاوله حوار واحده
لايجاد مخرج من هذا راينا ماكرون بعد حمله
بعد
اطلق الحوار الوطني الكبير ودار البلاد
واطلق حوار وطني ومن بعد هذا الحوار
الوطني
بنتائج ملموسه ترضي كل الاطراف
الامور على ما هي عليه واستمرت الحكومه
على موقفها فالامور مرشحه الى مزيد بطبيعه
الحال ان كل يوم درابيه عزيزي في فرنسا
يؤثر على الاقتصاد الفرنسي ما يتراوح بين
مليار الى مليارين يورو
كافه الاسعار تؤكد ذلك ولكنها ليست دقيقه
بالتحديد لانها لا تعتمد على ارقام واضحه
وثابته ولكن هذا تاثير اغلب الدراسات تؤكد
على ذلك كما تؤدي ايضا على تاثير بين
تنخفض العطاء او الانتاجيه في فرنسا حوالي
20% في كل يوم ادراك ولكن هنا دعني اقول
عن امور يعني اؤكد على امور ضروريه جدا
بيختلف الموضوع من مدينه الى اخرى ويختلف
عن الموضوع من انقطاعا الى اخر ويختلف
الموضوع حسب قوه الاضراب وحسب عدد
المضربين او المتظاهرين في الشارع فمثلا
اذا ما اخذنا بلده موجوده فبعيده عن عن
الاضرابات فهي لن تتاثر بطريقه مباشره اما
باريس والمدن الكبرى بردو ولوز فهي متاثره
جدا في هذه الاضرابات
قطاعات التي تتاثر اكثر من غيرها هي
قطاعات السياحه وقطاعات
او ما يسمى
السياحه يعني المطاعم والسياحه وغيرها
وكما يقال رب ضاره نافعه لبعض القطاعات
التي تستفيد من هذه الاضرابات هي قطاعات
المبيعات اون لاين في بعض الاماكن تستفيد
لان المبيعات في السوق
الفيزيائي يعني الذهاب الى السوق وهناك
صعوبه في التجول وصعوبه في التسوق ولكن
المبيعات اون لاين تستفيد في هذه ليس
بالتحديد في اليوم بحاله ولكن تشكل عند
المواطن حاله من الشراء اونلاين
هذه امور لابد من الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
يعني اذا سمحت لي فقط لاعطي
موضوع
حقه فيما يتعلق ايضا
ثقافه الفرنسي وثقافه الانسان بعد ازمه
كوفيد كيف اصبحت يعني اصبح
الامور يعني اونلاين اكثر فاكثر فاذا ما
اخذت التعليم مثلا فاذا ما كان هناك اضراب
قبل الكوفيد وقبل الاضرابات هذه اي يوم
اضراب كان يؤدي الى التعطيل عن التعليم
يعني هذه الامور يتحطها المضربون اما
اليوم فاذا كان هناك
عمليه اضراب فقال التعليم يمكن ان يحصل
اونلاين وهذا نشهده يعني في الجامعات
وفي المؤسسات التعليميه طبعا ربما
السنويات ولكن في الجامعات وفي المؤسسات
التعليميه الاخرى بس دكتور حسن سؤال سالته
للسيد حسان القطبي لماذا لا تستطيع
الحكومه الفرنسيه والرئيس مكرون التراجع
او تجميد العمل بالقانون الى اجل يعني غير
مسمى من اجل امتصاص خطبه الشارع سمعت بعض
المحللين الاقتصاديين والماليين الموالين
للحكومه ويؤيدون مقترح الرئيس ماكرون
يقولون ايا تكن التداعيات في الشارع فان
وجود هذا القانون هو افضل من لا شيء على
المستوى الاقتصادي والمالي لفرنسا في
المستقبل الى اي مدى هذا الكلام دقيق ولو
نشرح الامور من الزاويه الاقتصاديه
نعم من الناحيه الاقتصاديه ان الصندوق
التقاعد في فرنسا يعاني يعني اذا ما
شاهدنا يعني العمر المتقاعدين في اوروبا
بشكل عام وعمر البطاقات في فرنسا نجد ان
الفرنسي عنده افضليه على الاوروبي وهذا
القانون
يعني لابد ان يمر ولكن توقيته ليس توقيت
سليم لماذا لانه لم نزل الخارجي نخرج من
ازمه كوفيد بعدنا هلا
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه ونصف التضخم في
فرنسا تتراوح يعني تتخطى السته بالمئه
القدره الشرائيه في فرنسا وفي اوروبا بشكل
عام انخفضت ليس الوقت الان هو لهذا القرار
يعني لكان لابد من
المناقشه هذا القرار ربما في بدايه الشتاء
القادم في سبتمبر ربما في الصيف ولكن ليس
اليوم اليوم المشكله كبيره جدا ولم يزل
الفرنسي خارج من ضائقه اقتصاديه لم يزل
يعاني من ضائقه اقتصاديه كبيره ولكن بما
انه اتخذ القرار الحكومه حكومه بون اتخذت
القرار والرئيس الفرنسي اتخذ القرار
فاصبحت الامور خرجت عن السيطره الاقتصاديه
والعقلانيه الاقتصاديه لتذهب الى مكان
سياسي اخر بين واصبحت موضوع ليزراء ما بين
اليمين المتطرف واليسار من ناحيه وهم
معارضون للحكومه الفرنسيه ومعارضون
لماكرون ولكن
ليسوا متفقين فيما بينهم على الامور
الاخرى متفقون على معارضه
هذه الاطراف هذه اليمين المتطرف وبين
وجود الفرنش يؤثر على صوره فرنسا يؤثر على
حقوق الانسان وعلى وعلى الثوره الفرنسيه
بحد ذاتها ولذلك لابد من الجلوس الى طاوله
ولابد من الحوار بين المتظاهرين وانت
تتحدث يعني
المصادر الاحتجاجات
تؤكد ان 450 الف متظاهر يشاركون اليوم في
هذه التظاهرات في عموم فرنسا يعني 450 الف
متظاهر تقترب الامور من نصف مليون
شخص
هل تتوقع ان تتراجع الحكومه او على الاقل
تجمد العمل نتيجه هذا الضغط
الشعبي ام لا يعني
الحكومه تراهن على انه مع الوقت ستبرد همه
هؤلاء المتظاهرين
وينصعون لهذا
القرار باعتباره دي فاكتور
اذا ما لاحظنا تطور الامور انه في جويات
من العمل
المنحرم
اخذت الحكومه قرار
49.3
واصبح هناك واد حاولت المعارضه
طرح الثقه بالحكومه لم تحصل على ذلك وهذه
السنه
من تفكير محطات الوقود الى اخره احاول هنا
يعني رابطه الامور ببعضها
اصبحت متدرجه الامور يعني منذ ولايه
ماكرون الثانيه كوفيد
اضف اليه الحرب الاوكرانيه تدرجت الامور
الى مظاهرات ضئيله ثم مظاهرات اكبر واليوم
اكثر مظاهره حتى ان بعض
التصريحات نقول ان اكثر من 450 حوالي 650
الف شخص في الشارع اذا
يعني شاهدنا كافه المعطيات ولكن ليس
بالمؤكد فاذا الامور تتطور اكثر واكثر
القدره الشرائيه تقل اكثر واكثر
اليوم اضف الى ذلك
تشهده اوروبا وتشهده العالم من ازمه
اقتصاديه لم نزل خارجي من سيليكون فالي
بنك
وما هو وما هو البنك القادم اليوم
الس
لطات الفرنسيه الى القضاء تهمه تبييض
الاموال فاذا نحن نعيش في ازمه اقتصاديه
ماليه
سياسيه كبيره اذا ما استمر الوضع عليه
فالموضوع ذاهب الى تازم اكثر والى مظاهرات
اكثر ولهذا العنف الذي نشهده في فرنسا لم
نكن نشهده في ما قبل بهذه الطريق يعني
نشهد طريقه عنصيه والعنف ياتي من ماذا
ياتي من من الموضوع من حقد او ليس بالطريق
بالتحديد والكياتي من
من الحرمان ياتي من
احباط في مكان ما فاذا الموضوع اعتقد انه
سيقوم اذا ما كان هناك ليس خبير دستوري
ولكن اعتقد ان لابد منه تعليق العمل في
هذا القانون او الجلوس الى طاوله سيتراجع
حسب اعتقادي وحكومته او ربما تستقل
الحكومه او ربما يطلب ماكرون
باعاده مجلس النواب واعاده يعني انتخابات
جديده
لطرح هذا الموضوع على المجلس النيابي
الجديد
فقط لو سمحت لي يعني انت تتوقع انه يصير
في تجميد او
تراجع ولكن ذكرت الموضوع الاوكراني
والفتوره التي تدفع للحرب في اوكرانيا
البعض من المنتقدين لسياسه الرئيس الفرنسي
والمكروه ويقولون لو لم يكن هناك فاتوره
تدفعها فرنسا للحرب في اوكرانيا لما كانت
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والماليه وصلت الى ما
وصلت اليه هل يمكن الربط بشكل غير مباشر
بين حجم هذه التظاهرات ويعني هذه الغضبه
الشعبيه
بموضوع يعني الفاتوره التي تدفعها كل
اوروبا وليس فقط فرنسا لاوكرانيا
لتمويل هذه الحرب
بشكل غير مباشر طبعا ولكن بشكل
في اللاوعي المواطن الفرنسي ليس عنده نقمه
على الحكومه الفرنسيه لانها شاركت في في
الحرب الاوكرانيه او مساعده اوكرانيا او
دفعت من الفاتوره الاوكرانيه ولكنه في في
الحياتيه وفي حياته اليوميه لا ينظر الى
هذه الامور بتفاصيلها ينظر الى قدرته
الشرائيه وينظر الى مستقبله لذلك
اذا ما فعلته هل انت ستقوم بمظاهره لانه
تم هناك مشاركه فرنسيه في اوكرانيا سيقول
لك بالعكس انا مع هذه المشاركه ولكن عندما
تقوم قدرته الشرائيه سيقوم بالمظاهره ففي
حقيقه الامر وبحقيقه الامر انما ادى الى
ما ادى اليه اليوم وعلما وصلنا اليه اليوم
في اوروبا هي بطبيعه الامر ليس فقط دفع
فاتوره ماليه مباشره للحرب الاوكرانيه لكن
هي
الخلاف او العقوبات التي وضعت على الروسيه
التي ادت الى استيراد اليوم الطاقم باسعار
مضاعفه ومضروبه بثلاثه واربعه باسعار
غاليه جدا وما ادى الى زياده التضخم في
اوروبا وانخفاض القدره الشرائيه للمواطن
الاوروبي من باريس المحلله الاقتصاد
الدكتور حسن عبيد شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه دكتور حسن اعود الى مراسل
العربيه في باريس فريد دهوك الذي يتابع
تطورات هذا المشهد فادي اهلا بك مجددا كيف
يبدو المشهد بالنسبه اليك في هذه الاوقات
وهل الامور ذاهبه الى مزيد من التصعيد في
الساعات المقبله
اهلا طالب حدثت قبل قليل بعض المواجهات مع
عناصر الشرطه لكنها كانت محدوده
المتظاهرون قاموا بتحطيم بعض واجهات
المصارف التي لم تتمكن من تركيب واجهات
خشبيه او معدنيه كما ان العناصر الذين
تحدث عنهم وزير الداخليه من يسار او من
شبان اليسار في فرنسا وهؤلاء يسميهم
اليسار المتطرف قاموا بمهاجمه عدد من
الصحفيين كنا بجوار مجموعه من الصحافيين
الذين يصورون هذه الاشتباكات طلبوا منا
انزال الكاميرا لكن احد مراسلي شبكه سي ان
امريكيه لم يسمع ربما فقاموا بتكسير
كاميرته راينا ذلك امامنا مباشره
المواجهات خفت الان الموكب مازال يسير في
طريقه وفي المسار المحدد له نلاحظ ايضا ان
هناك لا يوجد انتشار امني في الازقه التي
حول التظاهره كما جرت العاده سابقا ربما
هذا الامر لتجنب حدوث تصعيد لان بمجرد
مشاهده هؤلاء المتظاهرين خصوصا اليسار او
شبان اليسار المتطرفين بمجرد ان يشاهدوا
عناصر من الشرطه يبداون بالمناوشات معهم
والحوارات الحاده التي تفضي في النهايه
الى اشتباكات حتى الان لم نرها او لا
الشرطه منتشرين في الازقه لكنهم موجودين
حوائل حوالي هذه
الساحات وفي موكب التظاهره هناك عدد كبير
جدا من عناصر الشرطه وايضا من الدرك
الفرنسي هناك كما ذكرت الاشتباكات حتى
الان متركزه في مناطق اخرى في مدن فرنسيه
في اليوم وسط فرنسا في في بوردو اصلا ايضا
وكذلك في مدينه نونت ورين كان هناك
مواجهات عنيفه بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين
طبعا يدخل على خط هذه المواجهات ليس فقط
شبان اليسار المتطرفين ولكن ايضا عناصر من
اليمين المتطرف كما هو في مدينه بوردو
الاسبوع الماضي قاموا باحراق مدخل بلديه
مدينه بوردو وهذه كانت نادره الحدوث لم
تحدث حتى الان على الاقل في العاصمه فادي
على مستوى المواقف السياسيه اخر المواقف
يعني سمعنا منذ قليل لوزير الداخليه يتحدث
عن حل بعض الجمعيات
الفرنسيه باعتبارها جمعيات متطرفه هذا
واحد اثنين عندما تتجول جميع المطاعم
المحال التجاريه مقفله تماما ام لا في بعض
المطاعم ما زالت يعني تفتح ابوابها برغم
كل التظاهرات
نعم امامي الان هناك عدد كبير من المقاهي
والمطاعم التي ما زالت مفتوحه وهناك عدد
كبير من الزبائن يتواجدون فيها لا يوجد
استهداف حقيقه للمطاعم او للمقاهي لكن ما
يحدث هو استهداف
بشكل خاص للمصارف وشركات التامين
المطاعم التي تقدم الوجبات السريعه وهي
تكون سلسله المطاعم الامريكيه على سبيل
المثال كل هذه المهاره هذه المراكز
يعتبرونها تمثل راس المال الذي يحتاجون
بظهر لذلك يقومون باستهدافها لكن لا
يستهدفون المطاعم العاديه الصغيره او حتى
المقاهي الفرنسيه هناك عدد كبير من
المطاعم التي ما تزال مفتوحه حتى في موكب
التظاهر حيث تمر هذه التظاهره ولا احد
يختلف منها
ولشركات التامين بشكل خاص
طيب على مستوى القرارات هل من قرارات بحل
جمعيات من وزير الداخليه باختصار
نعم هو قام بالاعلان عن علمه حل احدى
الجمعيات التابعه لليسار كما
قام سابقا بحال جمعيات فادي سنتابع هذه
التغطيه معك في نشرات وتغطيات لاحقه
اعزائي المشاهدين هذا كل شيء حتى الساعه
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته